indeed i don't want to put any pressure
on him but he is my pick to win the
tournament
so about time
yes indeed a good win today
uh he played very aggressively against
you in the opening how did you feel
about how that went uh from the start
it wasn't too much of a surprise because
he played this way in the first round
um
and and
i guess he trusts in the opening i mean
it's a good line for black
but it is very double-edged uh the thing
is i i don't really like these types of
positions with white because you know
white is always in danger of getting
mated
um
but it is high high risk high reward um
so black
black's queen side is really suffering
and he's sort of putting his hopes on
the king's side and
and a slow attack
um but he never got time to do it which
was which was sort of my hope now
our folks here were complaining about
the move uh night a5
uh when it happened as you you castled
and went into this but did it seem to be
a moment after you played a4
where he could have played for the move
b4
and knight c6 knight a5 is a fine move
it's not
forced but i think it's probably the
best move knight c6 is a very big
mistake yeah he should play b4
um take so now his bishop on a7 is
really alive
and uh and now he goes back knight c6
uh and this is
you know very dangerous for white as
well so i have to play b5
uh i i have to stop him from
having time to play you know h5 h4 etc
and now
knight d4 is a good move knight d7 is a
good move
um
both are complicated
i'll just show one line because anyway i
i don't think this is like a super
important opening a knight e7
knight c3
so the whole point is that after g4
knight h4 my king side becomes solid
right um
and here his attack doesn't really go
through so knight g6 is preparing g4 so
that my knight on h4 can get taken
um and now i play knight d5 to
to prepare b6 basically to to restrict
his bishop so g4
and this is all
not entirely forced but pretty forced b6
enter mezzo
uh cb6 he wants to keep his bishop alive
without that bishop there's no attack
knight
h4
take take
queen h4
so knight c7 is
is not really a worry for him
because his attack will be very strong
so g3 i have to stop g3 from him queen
h3
yeah now h5 is on the cards but i can
play d4 h5 h4 is a bit slow um there's
ways to defend against that so like b5
is the best move
oh which one's the best one right now d4
d4 b5 he wants to i mean that's the key
piece for him otherwise he's he's losing
by that bishop rook a3 is sort of
useful
um
a useful uh
move defending g3 in some cases
uh bishop d or wait was it
i think it was actually a b5 was a move
instead of rook a3
a b5
yeah bishop d4 so now queen g3 is a
threat and i can play queen d4
hello ed4 and there's knight f4 uh
trapping the queen but i don't have to
trap the queen yet i can play rook fd1
because the queen can't escape from h3
that's right rook fd1 okay
f
that's hilarious so that the queen
cannot though so you can't play
one
with knight f4 coming
and it's actually not better for white
no this this loses the queen for nothing
so he has to keep the queen there and
eventually lose it but um
but we end up with a
roughly equal end game which is kind of
funny after i take that queen
uh is this analysis or
computer generated variation yeah i
didn't figure this out over the board
okay
mighty upset if you had said oh i looked
at all of this
wow what a line okay so
so you you had some preparation before
john walked into this mess not knowing
the the niceties so he didn't find b4
and instead he played knight c6 and it
looked like he just got
yeah
i don't know how bad it is but it's it's
definitely unpleasant he doesn't have
time the point is rook b8 knight b5 like
at this point i think we were both on
our own but it wasn't difficult to to
figure out these variations
rook b5 bishop a4 and
his queen side collapses bishop a6 i
take in c4 and i win the
bishop
um
so he's he's never really in time i
actually thought he would sack the b
pawn
for example with bishop b6
um
instead of rook b8
at least there he gets to trade rooks he
gets rid of his awkward pieces
bishop b6 fish b6 doesn't do much
take take knight e7 i mean
it doesn't look good for black his
attack isn't really going through but
at least he has the two bishops yeah
yeah yeah it's not being
tied down as in the game on the queen
side it's it's got some kind of flow
going on the king side yeah no i was
surprised bishop a6 because
it keeps the pawn but it looks like
bowling pins i called it yeah and the
line just some something bad is going to
happen
uh yeah it just looks wrong
um
everything is based on his king side
attack and he's moved all the pieces
away
from there i mean
um
yeah i always thought it was good but
maybe i had something better
than this i don't know
right here you also came up with the
enterprising rook takes a7 yeah i
thought about it taking queen h5 yeah it
looks super dangerous because king g7
bishop f7 is winning yeah
but i thought he'll play d5
ed queen d6
and i didn't see
like knight i have knight b5 but then
after queen c5 my knight might get
stranded right um
and i thought this is
unnecessary because cb4 looked like a
clean pawn
uh it might still be good but uh
i don't know i was happy with
with the position i had i think they i
remember wasn't the engine giving c5
guys same idea same idea
c5 first i thought it was d5 c5 take on
c6 and now queen d6 right and take
amazon now queen d6 to try remarkable uh
defense by the computer
d5 and c5 i was like what
nice that amazing but you're you you
actually made a really accurate decision
in not
taking the exchange but simply what you
did capture was very strong uh
it i mean john tried to put up
resistance but everything is bad he's
got the wrong
setup i thought he would just play
bishop b6 and
um
he's not going for activity he's
accepting he's just a pawn down right
yeah double pawns he won't yeah i have
double pawns
um the problem is that his light squares
on the king side are so weak
that
it looks like white is the one also with
the better position
not just upon advantage you have you
have ponding compensation
and the game proceeded kind of nicely
for you uh we one final point on the
game is
you played the move
king h2 at the end if you could take a
look at that
that last moment we felt like you were
kind of sadistic
playing king h2 or was it just so that
he couldn't play queen f2 check
no i i mean king h2 is just telling him
now it's time to resign
yeah yeah that's what we thought that
was our interpretation as well d6 also
wins a piece and in general any move
wins
i instead of king h2 d6 wins a piece but
why i mean i don't have to calculate
anything king h2 and he doesn't have a
single
single move so right
yeah that's uh that's a good lesson for
the young junior champion from last year
right at the ship feeling like you're
flowing in the right direction after two
difficult games of black
um
well not with i was white in the first
oh sorry you you had white i remembered
somebody else though yeah yeah yesterday
was a miracle so
it's not often that happens especially
against the player as strong as linear
so
we take those
all right well keep on going remember
you're my pick to win that that means a
lot
no pressure
congratulations
congrats papi and good luck in the rest
of the tournament i think it's time